people think I'm a raging [__]
because of the stuff I talk about on my
podcast I'm activated I'm online I'm on
the I'm you know I post a real of me
bitching about the food in my rehab or
you know talking about [__] about
Rihanna whatever it is this is a 60
second clip online that I'm posting and
people go [__] this guy they don't know
that after that after I do my podcast I
go I cuddle with my child I kiss my wife
we watch something really nice on TV
Like A Bug's Life you don't get to see
those tender moments you don't get to
see the real person moments you just see
what I put on Instagram Tick Tock me
yelling about a [__] dry cleaning
service or whatever happened
and I seem activated and so you think
that guy's a [__] or you think that
guy's got it made because I took a
picture of my [__] car with the
bloody guts oops
and yeah I stack Gaper but do you know
what's going on in my mental but that's
fine I don't mean to make this about me